ارتفاعهن كبير بمعدلات تحميله حققه تطبيق
لمن ثمانيه تابع لشركه بايد دانس الصينيه
ملكه تطبيق تيك توك في الولايات المتحده
مؤخرا
التقارير التقنيه كشفت ان التطبيق استغل
الازمه الحاليه ليصعد القمه متجاوزا بذلك
تطبيقات عملاقه كواتساب وفيسبوك وجيميل
ويوتيوب ونتحدث هنا عن معدلات تحميل هذا
التطبيق في الولايات المتحده طبعا خبراء
تطبيقات السوشيال ميديا علقوا على هذا
التصاعد بان التحميل الصاروخي لثمانيه وهو
حيله ذكيه من الشركه الصينيه للتخلص من
الضغوط الامريكيه التي ترغمها على بيع تيك
توك او مواجهه حظره واضاف الخبراء ان
الشركه الام لتيك توك
وهي بيت دانس استهدفت المؤثرين ومستخدمي
تيك توك بشكل رسمي وبدات في وضع
خوارزميتها على هذا الاساس لتكون قادره
على اشتداب الاعداد الضخمه على تيك توك
وبالتالي نقلهم الى ثمانيه
فيما يتخوف مسؤولونه امريكيون من قدره هذا
التطبيق على التجسس وتحميل المزيد من
بيانات الامريكيين وارسالها للحزب الشيوعي
الصيني تطبيق الليمون ثمانيه الذي اطلقته
يشبه بشكل كبير تطبيق انستجرام وكيفيه
عمله وما اعتبره البعض خطوه تنافسيه
لانستجرام
ثمان هي
هو عباره عن منصه منصه وسائط اجتماعيه
لمشاركه الفيديو والصور تلبي اهتمامات
المستخدمين في الطعام الجمال الصحه وكذلك
السفر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات